let's say that f of X is equal to x
squared x squared plus X minus 6 over X
minus 2 and we're curious about what the
limit of f of X as X approaches to is
equal to now the first attempt that you
might want to do right when you see
something like this is to see what
happens what is f of 2 now this won't
always be the limit even if it's defined
but it's a good place to start just to
see if something reasonable could pop
out so looking at it this way if we just
evaluate F of 2 on our numerator we're
going to get 2 squared plus 2 minus 6 so
it's going to be 4 plus 2 which is 6
minus 6 you're going to get 0 in the
numerator and you're going to get 0 in
the denominator so we don't have the
function is not defined so not defined
at X is equal to 2 F not defined so
there's no simple thing there even if
this did evaluate if it was a continuous
function then it actually the limit
would be whatever the function is but
that doesn't necessarily mean the case
but we see very clearly the function is
not defined here so let's see if we can
simplify this and we'll also try to
graph it in some way so one thing that
might have jumped out at your head is
you might want to factor this expression
on top so if we want to rewrite this we
could rewrite the top expression and
this is goes back to your algebra one
two numbers whose product as negative
six whose sum is positive 3 well that
could be positive 3 and negative 2 so
this could be X plus 3 times X minus 2
all of that over X minus 2 so as long as
X does not equal 2 these two things will
cancel out so we could say this is equal
to this is equal to X plus 3 X plus 3
for all X's except for X is equal to 2
as long as X does not equal 2 so that's
another way of looking at another way we
could rewrite our f of X do it in blue
just to change the colors we could
rewrite f of X this is the exact same
function f of X is equal to X plus 3
when X does not
does not equal two and we could even say
it's undefined it's undefined when X is
equal to two so given this definition it
becomes much clearer to to us of how we
can actually graph f of X so let's try
to do it so that is that is not anywhere
near being a straight line
that is much better so let's call this
the y-axis I'll call it y equals f of X
and then let's rover here let me make a
horizontal line that is my x-axis so
defined this way f of X is equal to X
plus 3 so if this is one two three we
have a y-intercept at three and then the
slope is one the slope is one but it's
defined and it's defined for all X's
except for X is equal to two so this is
X is equal to 1 X is equal to 2 so when
X is equal to 2 our it is undefined so
let me make sure I can so it's undefined
right over there it's undefined
undefined right right over there so this
is what this is what f of X this is what
f of X looks like now given this let's
try to answer our question what is the
limit of f of X as X approaches 2 well
we can look at this graphically as X
approaches 2 from lower values into so
right over it so this is this right over
here is X is equal to 2 if we get to
maybe let's say this is 1 point 7 we see
that our f of X is right over there
if we get to 1 point 9 our f of X is
right over there so it seems to be it
seems to be approaching this value right
over there
similarly as we approach 2 from from
values greater than it if we're at like
I don't know this could be like 2.5 2.5
our f of X is right over there if we get
even closer to 2 if we get even closer
to our f of X is right over there and
once again we look like we are
approaching this value or another way of
thinking about if we ride this line from
the positive direction we seem to be
approaching this value for f of X if we
ride this line from the negative
direction from values less than 2 we
seem to be approaching this value right
over here and this is essentially the
value
of X plus 3 at X if we said X is equal
to 2 so this is essentially going to be
this value right over here is equal to 5
if we just look at it visually if we
just graphed a line if we just graphed a
line with slope 1 with a y-intercept of
3 this value right over here is 5 now we
can also try to do this numerically we
can also try to do this numerically so
let's try to do that so if this is our
function definition completely identical
to our original definition completely
identical to our original definition
then we just try values as X gets closer
and closer to 2 so let's try values less
than 2 so 1.999 this is almost obvious 1
point 9 9 9 9 9 plus 3 plus 3 well that
gets you pretty darn close to 5 if I put
even more 9 so your got even closer to
we'd get even closer to 5 here if we
approach 2 from the positive direction
and then we once again we're getting
closer and closer to 5 from the positive
direction if we were even closer to 2
we'd be even closer to 5 so whether we
look at it in numerical here we look at
it graphically it looks pretty clear
that the limit here the limit here is
going to be equal to 5